- [Instructor] We're told that
Ricky is going on a road trip
that is 100 kilometers long.
His average speed is
70 kilometers per hour.
At that speed, he can
drive five kilometers
for every liter of fuel that he uses.
Fuel costs
.60 dollars per liter.
So the equivalent of 60 cents per liter,
but they wrote it as
.60 dollars per liter.
What is the cost of fuel for the trip?
Pause the video and see if
you can figure that out.
All right, so let's see what
information they gave us.
They tell us that the trip
is 100 kilometers long.
They tell us that the average speed
is 70 kilometers per hour.
So 70 kilometers per hour.
They tell us that at that speed,
he can drive five kilometers
for every liter of fuel that he uses.
So five kilometers per liter.
And then they tell us that fuel costs
0.60 dollars per liter.
So then this last piece of
information right over here
is that fuel costs 0.60 dollars per liter.
Normally we would see that
written as 60 cents per liter,
but let's just go with it this way.
So what's going to be
useful for the total cost
of the fuel for the trip?
Well, we need to figure out
how much fuel we're going to use,
and then multiply that,
times the cost of the fuel.
So how much fuel are we going to be using?
Let's see, we're going 100 kilometers,
that's the total distance.
And then this tells us,
essentially how many liters
we're going to have to use
over those 100 kilometers.
Now you might say, how
exactly does that work?
Well if I'm going five
kilometers per liter,
if I were to take the
reciprocal of this information,
I would get one fifth of a liter,
of a liter,
per kilometer.
That's how much fuel I use per kilometer.
One fifth of a liter.
And so why is that useful?
Well if I take 100 kilometers,
and if I were to multiply,
times 1/5th of a liter per kilometer,
this is going to tell you
that over the course of this trip,
I am going to use 100 times 1/5th liters.
Or this is going to tell us
that over the course of the trip,
we're are going to use 20 liters.
And then if we were to multiply that,
times the cost of fuel per liter,
well then we know how much
the cost of our trip is.
So let's do that.
Then let's multiply this,
times 0.60 dollars per liter,
which is the same thing
as multiplying this,
times 0.60 dollars per liter.
The liters cancel out,
so it's good that our units work out.
We're left with just dollars here.
So 20 times 0.60
is going to get us to 12.
So we are left with 12 dollars.
And we're done, that's
the cost of our trip.
And I know what you're thinking.
Wait, we didn't use the
information right over here,
that he's traveling an average speed
of 70 kilometers per hour.
It's true, we did not use
it in our calculation.
Although it was kind of
useful because we had to know
what his fuel efficiency
is, at that speed.
So they're saying, they're traveling
at 70 kilometers per hour,
then at that speed, we
get this fuel efficiency.
Now they could have just told us,
they didn't even have to tell us this,
they could have just told us,
at whatever speed he's going,
his fuel efficiency is this.
And we still would have
been able to figure out
the total cost of the fuel for the trip.